[Musique]
ça c'est le costume de vampire le plus
haut de gamme qui puissent exister sur
le marché
ouais voilà finition elle le rend ultra
réalistes et ont pu s'aventurer l'a4 le
tissu c'est le même que dans macula ah
ouais trop trop bien et il a combien il
est pas cher
il est à 120 ou dans les mecs à ce prix
là je te le fais moi le costume de
majordome attend on voit que ça costume
de vampire l'exagèrent je suis un peu
plus loin avec un bas vois tu t'es bien
rideau avec la cape c'est du satin tous
les cosplayeurs utilisent ce matin tu
vois dracula très bien eh ben c'est le
plus proche qui existent au monde je
crois sur l'info la clau tu connais pas
en tissu toi ça va tomber c'est marouane
je connais est normal
franchement je kiffe le costume d'avocat
mais du coup je t'appelle m ou 1
j'aimerais que tu as une soirée humour
en fait juste pas prévenu juge
d'instruction géant vampire ça soit pas
c'est un vampire à 120 balbala mais
c'était pièce qui naîtra de travers la
tablette merci et je suis un vampire
toi t'es qui toi t'es quoi toi ta bille
envieux c'est halloween me saoule et
tout cela au cul le poisson qui s'ils
ont tout ça c'est un vampire ça 120 me
suis bien fait [ __ ] et mec c'est toi
qui peux chanter un vampire ouais c'est
moi et pourquoi il ya un problème avec
[Musique]
ce qui va la prendre tout ça on est où
là bas là on est dans le couloir entre
le cours de géo transylvanienne et lv2
chauve souris
alors choisissez une blague aussi c'est
une convention de geeks mais je pars pas
trop dans le délirant fait l'x et qui
bique monsieur guy oui le professeur
monsieur guy convention de monsieur guy
c'est tout à l'heure mais pourquoi tu me
parles de profs là je battais à l'école
quoi bâtiment bien gentil mais bon je
suis pas l'école
ces conneries depuis depuis longtemps
t'inquiète ici on est dans la section
des 800 ans
enfin par kevin hill à 1200 ans
il a redoublé waouh c'est original que
fringues à trouver ça ou pas dans une
petite boutique le type d'encre 11e à
paris trois fois rien et où on les a
récupérés sur les corps de nos victimes
bah ouais comme tout le monde quoi on va
y aller ça lui a plu attendez
parfait comme ça
[Musique]
ok
alors moi le g10 et de vous faire
emboutir exposé sur l'anatomie
tout d'abord nous avons des cas des
messages en musculature surdéveloppé et
par contre nous craignons la lumière
mais ça c'est dû au fait qu'on ait le
visage pâle enfants blancs will go j'ai
très bien matteo
par contre je dois préciser que les
textes anciens datent un peu hein
maintenant les vampires sont de toutes
les couleurs
allez tu peux t'asseoir lorsque nous
allons étudier aujourd'hui les groupes
sanguins et leur saveur j'ai goûté au
sénat ça vient de sortir s'est tue sa
mère
un saint nicolas le cours ne vous
intéresse pas même en fait madame
j'étais venu parler du coût mayotte tu
veux quoi
là j'arrive dans un des couloirs
principaux ou bien un mec avec un
costume de vampire un peu badiane à bord
enfin une personne normale possible
s'est réveillé dans les sorte de
cercueil la non non non moi je fais je
fais de l'urbex en fait là je fais une
petite exploration dans le château du
coût d'un château d'eau têtu tu sais où
on est là actuellement
oui on est dans le château au sommet de
la montagne la plus dense non et encore
non victoire si tu veux rester en vie
c'est pas comme ça qu'on se défend mais
n'ayez pas peur entre et ouais technique
du numéro une
[Musique]
je dracula puisque l'effet technique
numéro deux cours de défense contre les
chasseurs de vampires niveau 2 me qui
sont hyper relou est tu fini le travail
mais non maintenant il ya des chasseurs
de vampires aussi taré mais casse a fait
des milliers d'années qu'ils essaient de
nous tuer il faut qu'on apprenne à se
cacher à ses fonds parce que si nous
plaît à nous qu alors qu'on est déjà
mort et moi dit pont jean inuktitut
journée morts morts ça c'est votre mur
lève toi ok moi sinon mes vacances et
d50 loi et ce qu'ils voient ce que t'es
une merde t'es maire victor massé la vie
quoi ratu assez la mort du crawl ont
enfin compris toi mec tu t'appelles com
comme ça
[Musique]
gare aux retardataires vous êtes nouveau
n'ai pas peur entraîne en plus
aujourd'hui on va prendre un succès
alors je sais pas ce que c'est votre
délire mais mais moi je vais y aller
ouais reste la regarde voilà
montrez nous comment vous sucer moi ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais fois franc du collier voilà ça
fait bien bon allez vous moi alors vous
êtes des grands malades c'est fort non
mais là c'est encore un peu yvan bon
allez tu sais tu sais
ok ok je
et suse et j'y vais
[Musique]
je
je suis revenu c'était délicieux
merci à tous c'est une super expérience
puis je verrais tu arrêtes de me prendre
pour un con d'accord soit tu suces soit
tu vas au coin du plafond alors déjà
d'un je suivais gagnent 2 2 sa dalle au
plafond parce que je ne sais pas volé
parce que je ne suis pas un vampire mois
la base j'étais en soit avec mes potes
épouse on passe à un bon moment et là je
pense qu'alain des mecs de chez vous qui
est venu me chercher qui m'a à mon avis
ramener ici pour je ne sais quelle
raison
ben ouais c'est rené bah ouais c'est moi
à mon mec tu bois parce que là on veut
apprendre à sucer mais je ne suis pas un
vampire bordel vous le prouve
ok mais bon ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vais ouvrir ses rideaux
normalement si je suis un vampire
la lumière du soleil devrait me brûler
ou j'sais pas quoi au dixième degré on
s'inquiète le faire
après coup
[Musique]
voilà que dalle je pars à vampire
demandé mais qu'est il arrivé là
4 heures du matin mais vous n'en mais
quand vous le jour ouais logique
bon c'est un bon exemple autre chose la
donne à quoi ça c'est de l'argent
alors ça devrait me brûler aussi ouais
regardez
[Musique]
que dalle tu parle en bien
certes un petit peu mais je la base un
petit peu d'examen en fait que c'est bon
ça brûle à mort ok d'accord mais ça
c'est du toc donc j'ai mauvaise réaction
allergique c'est tout et c'est quoi ses
canines alors ça situe plastique ne
feront je les enlève
je montre fethi culte c'est pas très
bonne colle donc à ses collègues il faut
de l'eau chaude
autre exemple voilà de l'aïe
regardez bien
pour la base tous qui goûtait aux
oignons échalotes tu intolérants donc
516 doit taper dame
voilà j'ai pas d'âme je suis pas un
vampire tous les vampires n'ont pas
d'âme
abbassi wayne on gêne à moi j'suis pas
mentir et commence à juba dames 3 qui se
raconte
mais châteauroux bizarre
touche pas d'homme mois
le mec jaloux mec t'es où on t'attend
depuis une heure là qu'est ce tu fais je
fais un truc de ouf je suis pas au film
j'ai eu une sorte de château avec des
vampires
je suis mort facetime
on doit bien ça
voilà du mois mais qu'elle est
complètement défoncée on voit absolument
rien
waouh je suis pas un vampire mois moi je
suis un simple citoyen qui paye ses
impôts
ok d'accord qu'avec un temps aussi pâle
t'es pas un vampire ah ok on fait des
vannes on n'est pas postes dont tu peux
te calmer ouais [ __ ]
vous avez unique et mon costume là
la blague est trop longue à faut arrêtez
de me faire chier que vos histoires de
vampires epistola aulas c'est de l'eau
bénite et ben ça marche pas du tout
marquage mais j'ai très bien en général
se met quelques secondes à agir et ça
peut piquer ici ou bien ici bien
ça
à
[Musique]
oh
et c'est comme ça que je suis devenu un
vampire merci vraiment merci normal pour
ces témoignages
tu sais ici on est tous quelqu'un
d'autre et on ne se juge pas par exemple
patrick est un elfe cynthia c'est quoi
déjà un run un renard et simon est une
table basse on est ici ensemble et
maintenant pour en parler tu n'es pas
seul bon c'est mal compris ce qu'on en
fait je suis je suis vraiment un vampire
oui oui oui tu es un vampire
ok donc personne ne croit vous voulez
que vous le prouve à ok
[Musique]